[Musique]
arnaud ces banques répondent donner de
nouvelles lectures de la matière
pervertir nos sensations cet artiste
plasticien travail les métaux depuis 15
ans il est l'invité d'honneur de ce 8e
salon des heures de plaisir
l'originalité la qualité de son travail
la légèreté il le dit lui même il traite
la matière je dirais pour nous
surprendre et pour nous de faire
déclencher des émotions effectivement
c'est tout à fait ça il ya une espèce de
subtilité de douceur dans ses oeuvres
qui je pense vont pas laisser insensible
au public pour cette nouvelle édition 18
artistes ont répondu présent de la
sculpture de la peinture cette année une
majorité des oeuvres fait la part belle
à l'art abstrait on n'a pas donné tu
aimes mes ans il est clair que là on
vous savez l'art c'est quelque chose qui
entraîne des sensations qui entraîne des
images et donc je crois que la
commission qui met ça en place bon
réagit en fonction de ses émotions je
crois que c'est pour ça que ça va
peut-être vers l'abstrait plus cette
année ce sera peut-être plus figuratifs
l'année prochaine il faut se laisser
porter c'est important une exposition le
public est amené à voter pour son oeuvre
préférée remise des prix le dimanche 10
décembre
[Musique]